j'avais j'avais j'avais des gens sérieux
au téléphone de retard ça va j'ai envie
de dire on est bon je vais lancer je
vais ouvrir je vais ouvrir lé petit chat
histoire d'être bien je vais lancer j'ai
ouvert les petit chat
histoire d'être bien et on va se mettre
alors je vais attendre que ça arrive un
tout petit peu histoire que ce soit plus
ludique pour moi ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va regarder des parties et on va
les analyser
donc je sais pas où vous êtes attendait
un jeu en train de se faire une petite
galère à l'est la galère est terminée la
galère est terminée les tchats ne sont
pas ouverts mais ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va regarder des parties à et qu'on
va essayer de on a essayé de les évaluer
d'évaluer les positions et de discuter
ensemble je vais parler avec eux qu'avec
vous donc et voir un peu comment ça se
passe donc on va le faire je pense en
deux temps on va un petit peu regardé la
partie peut-être on fera un débrief
juste après la partie convient de
regarder pour voir les moments
importants je vais me répéter un
forcément désolé pour ceux qui regardent
en redif mais voilà le temps que les
gens arrivent pour qu'ils comprennent
bien le concept je leur dirai donc là on
a une candide il a fait h3 fourrage 5g
quatre fous g6 hockey et cavaliers c6
grand roque qui devrait arriver h3g 4
j'ai pas trop aimé
alors au cinq ici c'est parce que je
joue j'imagine que si faisait roc blanc
menacé cavaliers prendre 5 puisque sur
fou prend aux deux dames prend 1,2 il y
avait un problème on reviendra là dessus
on en rediscutera h 3g 4g pas trop aimé
et away on voit je crois j'ai quatre
sacres est vraiment un souci sur sur
cette diago j'ai pas trop aimé a salué
le lautaret you big boss à bruz sinon
qui a aimé le qui a aimé l'interview
d'hier faisait un peu troll ça vous a
plu
bon je voulu m'amuser un peu stories ici
tout est dit
ouais je les ai mis un troll il était en
sueur non les américains hier ouais donc
à 3g 4g pas trop j'ai pas trouvé ça
top-top honnêtement
maintenant cette dame ou est ce qu'elle
va peut-être même à laura moye gérant dé
6,1 de prouver à première vue parce que
j'ai pas envie de voir le cavaly
rebondir en a eu cinq sinon il apte à
créer le fou g6 il vend ses 5
j'aurais préféré en d6 je sais pas
pourquoi mais c'est 5
ça a l'air pas mal aussi écouter
pourquoi pas parce que l'on est à
lecavalier qui est sous pression et ça
va pas être facile à gérer
bon il faut peut-être qu'il aille
chercher le fou mais je crois g4g
vraiment pas aimé on y reviendra
il a fait cavalier g11 voit pas trop les
lots et je peux pas à zoomer sur les
lots malheureusement je peux pas où mais
spécifiquement sur les lots puis mais en
plus c'est pas c'est pas ça l'important
donc il a fait kg 1 bon là les noirs
sont beaucoup mieux on viendra sur la
partie après est généralement qu'on est
dans ce genre de situation il faut finir
le développement la dame des cas je
trouve que c'est un coup un petit peu
naïf parce qu'il touche une fois la tour
d'accord mais les blancs peuvent parer
la menace en créant une menace semaine
et après continuer leur développement
après c'est peut-être pas mauvais parce
que ça va bloquer le savent a bloqué le
la diagonale du fou mode façon les
blancs ont tellement fait n'importe quoi
je n'aurais pas fait ça mais c'est
peut-être pas c'est peut-être pas idiot
en réalité et les blancs je les vois pas
pouvoir laisser dame prend un faux tu
regardais les trucs de type qui a valu
aux deux dames croit un cahier c3 ça
marche quasi jamais mais là la dame et
quasiment fermée
il a fait ces trois dames f6
ok moncava lieu de rock ça devrait ça
devrait passer non d'un jeu de foot b2i
rock peut-être muret qui a valu aux deux
petits rock et peut-être dh 5 qui
arrivait avec les blancs s'il réussi à
sécuriser à rockets la position reste
dégueu mais mais ces gens-là position tu
reste en vie surtout si les blancs aussi
des noirs jouent avec petit rock
peut-être qu'on pourra faire h 4 h 5 et
réussir à faire tourner h3g 4 en notre
faveur avec avec les blancs peut-être il
faut juste finir le développement là de
façon rapide hausse et garder le h4 et
h5 peut-être si les noirs font petit
rock en réserve mais ça me semble ça me
semble assez logique foulée de la foulée
deux grands rock cavaliers c6 way est là
il faut vraiment envie de partir
un truc que tu pourras pas aller en b1 à
cause d'eux voyez quoi que tu pourras
peut-être tolérer le trois échecs en
faisant des trois parce qu'il faudrait
peut-être se barrer jusqu'en 1 avec le
roi et à la rigueur par la suite joué f3
salue le nex
en quoi peut-être il faut réussir à
ramener le roi
on verra par la suite avec edward
qu'est-ce que tu as comme plantu peut
avoir bon juste grand roque pour jouer
la colonne des tu peux avoir cave a lieu
cinq cavaliers detroit
taddei des dames e3 aussi pas mal pas
mal joué bloc ils bloquent la diagonale
du fou et il prépare cave a lieu deux
infos vraiment envie de faire ça fout
les cinq jeux pas trop me faut vraiment
vite sortir cette pièce assez horrible
cahier des trois échecs dames prend b2
c'est fini en fait c'est de revenir vers
la partie à quoi que dame prend des 3
j'avais pas vu honnêtement j'avais pas
vu sa c4 ça va juste paru tellement
tellement bizarre moi qu'il fallait pas
faire cavalier 5 direct fallait faire x
3 vous prend à trois cavaliers detroit
et ça marchait peut-être pas on va voir
mais à cette façon c'est tellement à
l'envers du jeu ce qui a été fait
c'était vraiment à l'envers et la fougue
quatre cette fois ci c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment gagner on va revenir il
ya beaucoup d'erreurs stratégiques qui
ont été faites avant dhabi côté blanc on
va laisser la partie se termine et le
font eux deux il est bien placé
voilà c'est tour deux mois ça va ça
randonnée ou pas d'ailleurs
pour l'aca semble vous promets que ça
semble terminée alors comment est-ce
qu'on va revenir sur la dernière partie
jouée par quelqu'un d'autre c'est pas
mal d'abandonner avec les blancs on va
faire l'analyse de la partie on va la
récupérer
est-ce qu'on peut comment comment faire
est ce que ces analyses en analysant
direct donc on va revenir sur la partie
eu quatre cavaliers f6 qui est ici trois
des cinq qui comprend qu'elle prend car
il ya trois fous g5 et prend des cinq
dames prend des cinq donc c'est un genre
de scandinaves où les noirs et peuvent
faire re 5 parce qu'ils échangent
utilisent ces trois contre le cavalier
f6 ok alors ici ce que je pensais pour
les blancs c'est au lieu de faire h3g
quatre peut-être faire rock avec l'idée
sur cavaliers six titres doit vérifier
que ça marche un mais de faire cavalier
prend 1,5
menace le fou fou prend 1,5 dame prend
1,5
je pensais qu'ils devaient jouer
peut-être cavaliers prend 1,5
essayer de placer un f4 je sais pas si
ça a marché je ne sais pas exactement ce
que ça pouvait donner ça pouvait être
une idée on va vérifier avec
l'ordinateur ce que ça donne bref ou c5
rouach un grand roque prises cinq c'est
vrai qu'il ya trop d'activités pour les
noirs ça va trop vite donc fou de
cavaliers c6 qui prend 1,5 semble pas
être un coup mais du coup peut-être
qu'il peut jouer lors 10 et 4 des quatre
tours e1 ça aurait été intéressant à mon
avis
quatre cavaliers g5 fou prend cavaliers
prend 4 tactique comme ça prend d un
cavalier six échecs trois des huit tours
8 matt joli mais en gros jouet cette
idée jouer la colonne a pris peut faire
foule à calais prend le cadre grand
roque prise de deux caïds et 4 il reste
hyper actif avec les noirs mais ok
introduire h3 pourquoi pas fou h5
maintenant peut-être toujours ses idées
de petit rock avec toujours ces
cavaliers prendre 5 qui peuvent rodez
est sûr qu a laissé six aussi à noter un
coup comme des cats peut être aussi une
option grand roque et ses quatre des
cinq peut être ça peut être une idée
donc sur des cats pas le temps de faire
grand roque
on peut prendre éventuellement prises
prise prises on a gagné la paire de fois
avec les blancs en quoi ça aurait pu
être cool
tout ça pour dire que ouais
roquet dans cette position est joué pour
la colonne et le roi qui restent au
centre c'est logique après g4g 6 b 3 ça
va pas du tout il s'affaiblit ici il
s'affaiblit ici ça pas du tout il a fait
le cat way pourquoi pas ça j'aime bien
repoussé quatre dames c5
je serai intuitivement plutôt parti en
décide quand même et c'est vrai que sur
dame ces cinq peut-être les blancs
l'opportunité de jouer des 4
ça permettait ça ce que puis on prend
fou prendrait plutôt content avec les
blancs tu a supprimé le pion aux 4 ea et
du cou et du coup tu as tu derrière le
jeu donc dame c5 sa santé que c'est une
case où elles pouvaient être touchés
fall est plutôt allé en d6 et d4 c'est
vraiment le coup qui illustrent que
c'est pas accès pas terrible d'amd 4-way
pourquoi pas en fait ils provoquent ces
trois dames m6 était plutôt bien joué ça
d'un me de fouet cette n'a peut-être en
voyage qu'attache cinq tours une option
mais foulée de pourquoi pas kéhi c6
grand roque grand roc dames 3 auquel
jusque là en fait ça j'ai bien aimé 9,3
et roye b 8 me donne un coup de répit et
ce qu'ils font est patente et cavalier e
2 pour se développer cavaliers 5 et
ouais bon sens mais c'est dégueulasse
genre cavale f4 je pensais l'essai qui
prend ses quatre dépensé 4 mais non mais
t'es faire c'est une cata
le fou en b2 est complètement fermé la
structure de pion est horrible non mais
ils pouvaient plus revenir dans la
partie et la sueur dame prend des trois
à voir qu'il pouvait faire un peu la
tactique que je vais montrer en direct
fois à trois dames c3 a pris ces trois
prix c3 est prise b2 avec la tour en d1
sur la colonne bon ouverture
raté pour les blancs et belle exécution
des noirs et on a vu qu'il fallait
essayer de tenter sa chance avec des
quatre sur dame c5
on va revenir sur cette française
ok je me demande si la après rock rock
s'il pouvait faire cavalier 5 direct
pour essayer de prendre le jeu il ya
peut-être des c5 qui sont pénibles bon à
je crois je pensais la théorie pour huit
sujets 5 et 17 ouais ça fait à peu près
ouais c'est à peu près la vente
théorique ce qu'il a joué il va réussir
à gagner la case 5
alors là généralement faut plutôt
prendre 2 h 1 quand on vous prend angers
six le plus tôt prendre 2 h et les
blancs ici pourrait continuer peut-être
partout reprend une scission prend aussi
ses dames pranger 6 histoire de mettre
une grosse pression sur le roi noir là
le sacrifice de qualité semble justifiée
parce que les pièces noires s'organise
pas du tout genre admettons tour f8 pour
venir couvrir à peut-être déjà fois six
cavaliers au 8 dame prend aussi si on a
déjà deux pions pour la qualité quand je
passe un peu vite mais c'est pour
illustrer et sur eve prend là les blancs
ont raté une énorme tactique ils ont
raté tout reprend 1,6 c'est quand même
dommage cavaliers 5-fu f5 dame b 3 ça
c'est bien joué du coût des six cas ici
six web et 6 qui sait si ça fait mal à
mon avis
bon allez encore raté une tactique il a
raté tout reprendre cette dame province
est fou progressiste d'un bref si ça me
prend des cinq fourchette
bon du coup il a joué le plan de m
lecavalier a eu 5 ce qui est bien joué
mais là il espère comment s'inscrire
l'aréna alors suivez besoin de lire je
peux vous les remettre
je peux vous trouvez les liens si vous
avez besoin
juste à temps une petite seconde il fait
dame prend des cinq maintenant et il va
il va petit à petit l'emporter bon une
partie intéressante par magie avec les
blancs sauf la petite erreur tactique
mois il a donné une super ça donne une
superposition blanc il fallait juste
voir les petites tactiques way
après je vais pas vous mentir je sais
pas exactement comment on fait pour
égaliser avec les noirs donc il faudrait
que le joueur qui a les noirs regarde la
théorie de son côté et la intéressant du
couffo prend h3 il joue sur le fait que
surpris on prend à je croyais et dames
problème deux échecs et l'avait le
joueur blanc il a encore raté un truc
l'a menacé d'un f2 il fait froid pour
protéger son pion à f2 mais il aurait pu
jouer tout reprend 4 pour tuer la taxe
sur f2 ça c'est parce qu'il n'a pas
regardé le dernier coup noir le cavalier
e 4 était attaqué le joueur noir à fait
fou prend h3 donc le le carré leucate
n'est plus protégé il a attaqué mais les
plus protégés donc on peut le prendre
et comme il n'a pas vraiment il s'est
pas concentré sur le fou qui s'est
déplacé il s'est juste concentré sur l'
attaque il a oublié que lecavalier était
plus en prix était et est plus protégé
et du coup ça le met un peu en danger
parce que maintenant c'est si c'est très
bien joué dames français 6 d'un
processus qui est français 6,6 à tout
repreneur
c'est dommage un là c'est vraiment des
erreurs tactiques de la part de gaffeur
fou bon il envoie le pion passé c'est un
bon réflexe mais là encore il regarde
pas du tout s'il ya pas des tours échec
qui les prend à f3 parce que le truc
c'est que tout réussit avec le roi bouge
cavaliers premières froidures touche le
fou donc le foot doit partir bref façon
le pion déliera pas bien loin on va
mettre une tour en d2 parlement h 5 des
6 g 4 3g trois tours des deux cavaliers
b8 disons et cavalli ou cinq blocs tout
et puis on n'avance pas bon alors il a
eu la chance que son adversaire voit
rien parce qu'après fo prend des six il
y avait peut-être une possibilité ipad
enfilade parce que surtout rossi ses
cavaliers des huit comprend des six
cavaliers à vii mais je suis pas sûr
qu'il l'ait vu donc en gros c'est parti
là dedans et cette finale aller mieux
pour les noirs mais il faut encore la
réaliser donc avec les noirs là faut
monter le roi et pousser les pions
mais le ranger ici c'est là pourrait
réussir à faire à h 5 h 4 et et g4
échanger f contre contre eux j'ai avoir
les deux pions pas scellier qui a valu
cavaliers ont eu 4 va être bien placé
les pièces mineurs sont bien placés la
sas entre eux protègent bien là avec les
blancs il a fait un bond un bon système
de défense il a aussi des fois fuite qui
peuvent rodez peut-être en faut surtout
pas perdre ah parce que si b est passé
ça fera du jeu sur les deux ailes il
faut pas qu'ils s'éloignent trop avec
son roi de la colonne âge parce que
sinon le pion va faire mal je pense que
le roi était plutôt bien placés en g3
pas ce qui l'empêché il couvrait il
couvrait le pion h
une façon avec les noirs s'il veut
progresser faut envoyer son pion passer
un mail aurait peut-être pu essayer de
l'envoyer quand le roi adverse était
était mal placé alors là y'a un truc
marrant ces croix g3 sa menace maths en
un et ça fait perpète tour g1
ouais matin alors ça c'est incroyable on
peut quand même revenir sur la partie
sur la finale j'ai envie de revenir sur
la fin de la finale parce qu'avant
c'était quand même un enchaînement
d'erreurs tactiques qu'on a plus ou
moins vu donc ce n'était pas forcément
c'était pas forcément ultra intéressant
par contre dans la finale là ce que je
veux juste montrer c'est surtout après
que le roi soit parti faut peut-être
tout de suite en profiter pour faire un
petit coup de tours à 2 le coupé et
après fait rage 5h 4h 3g
je sais pas ce que je voulais blanc en
réalité ici f4 t'as pas envie / kg 3 on
va faire peut-être g6 et on va essayer
de jouer h5 genre cavalier e 4 3 f cinq
caïds et 6 3 6 4
bref 5 et des 6/3 6/4 et là ok c'est pas
si simple de jouer de jouer h5 donc pour
ce faire on va peut-être jouer tout
rejet de 20 noms et en gros ce qu'on
veut c'est essayer envoyé le pion h
genre food et de admettons et peut-être
peut-être g4 déjà et on commence à créer
des changes de f contre eux j'ai et on
l'a on a créé une une vraie progression
avec les noirs on a vraiment réussi à
faire quelque chose après c'est pas
encore gagné mais on commence vraiment à
faire quelque chose en hockey même dans
la partie au f5 sakai et l'a peut-être
ici après roy f2 peut-être h5 quand même
le roi peut revenir en g3 mais h4 on
voit que ce pion il va aider avec les
noms on va réussir à faire des progrès
en menaçant tour g3 g4
mais il faut avancer la majorité comme
il l'a fait de mettre le roi devant il
avait peut-être une logique mais s'est
pas du tout passé la seule logique ça
aurait pu être de jouer g4 mais bon là
c'était pas possible puisque le pion g7
étaient attaqués donc il fallait
peut-être revenir avec le roi ait
recommencé à avancer avec les pions
ok
bien marche pas ils vous en voyez sont
censés marchèrent
ah le lien du tournoi tu à ton sujet
dans le club francophone vous devez le
voir dans les tournois alors on va aller
vers les dernières parties 4,5 et f3 qui
essaient 6 des quatre sur le cac et
prend des cartes et là qu'il prend des
quatre on l'a déjà vu mille fois c'est
une grosse erreur je sais pas comment
vous la fait encore j'ai déjà expliqué
je sais pas combien de reprises qu'on
ait changé pas en d4
parce que la dame en d4 pouvait plus
être chassé par le cavalier c6 donc il
faut surtout pas le faire et là sur
cavalia 6 de mémoire il ya eu 5 qui est
très fort parce que lecavalier est quasi
obligé de retourner en g8 s'y vend h 5e
g4 qui l'enferment donc ça encore c'est
des choses qu'on a déjà vu et revu
bon ça c'est pas mal il fait le il
sacrifie pour jouer pour l'attak a
préfère dames trois dames f2 damage
quatre peut-être ce genre de chose comme
ça c'est pas mal joué sacrifices et il
envoie le jeu après faut toujours se
méfier un le alger à certains moments ça
peut se mettre à marcher sur alger âgées
cavaliers prend 4 ici ça peut marcher
avec l'idée de faire [ __ ] angers 5 bon
ça reste hyper compliqué on va pas on va
pas se perdre
dames 17 on va dire qu'il a remis le
four 3 d'accord pour ce niveau c'est
déjà pas mal
et là c'est ridicule quand il fait b5
même si c'est un pion devant le rock il
faut quand même le prendre
ça va pas du tout ça non désolé un
défaut d'être un petit peu sévère avec
les joueurs mais mais fou prend b5 il
faut quand même le jouer ça permet de
prendre le pion et et d'éviter surtout
de se prendre b4
parce que quand tu es fou dessin qui
peut y avoir b4y s'ils attaquent le
cavalier il attaque le fou
c'est pas c'est pas très cool quoi de
laisser sa 35e rang des saints qui prend
des cinq dames prend des 5 pour m6 ou
france et 5 d'apple s'ils souffrent
décision après y ait eu un enchaînement
tactique temps d une petite seconde
j'ai oublié de faire un petit truc je
laissais la partie se dérouler juste une
minute sans l'analyser et je vais de
nouveau être là très rapidement
attendez attendez attendez j'ai oublié
de rajouter le tournoi sur une chaise
comme tv france ça va être fait tout de
suite donné pour une petite minute et on
va repartir et on va repartir tout de
suite
hop on profité de cette cette mauvaise
partie qu'est ce qui s'est passé les
quelques secondes je suis allé à me le
rendaient doit encore une erreur
tactique ça arrive
ça arrive ça arrive c'est la pression du
temps c'est plutôt bien ce qu'il fait
avec les blancs quand même il met ses
lycées tour c'est important quand vous
jouez contre une dame d'avoir vos pièces
qui centre protège donc c'est plutôt une
bonne idée d'avoir lié les tours ce que
dès qu'elles vont être décalés être
délié entre guillemets il pourrait y
avoir des double attaque
j'ai aucune idée avec les blancs comment
j'essaierai d'arnaqué ça le truc c'est
qu'il ya le pion à qui paris à leroy
faible avec fou c'est cet échec mais
surtout je vois pas comment on arrête à
5 à 4 à 3 qui paraît être le plan
logique ici bon il attaque son roi avec
le fouet la dame
ouais ce aussi bien joué
mais il va pouvoir raser le pion h4
envoyer aussi le pion à celle
éventuellement donc la gérante moyen de
clouage on prend pas tout de suite
on prend le temps prend d'abord h4 la
tourelle va pas s'envoler elle n'est pas
s'envoler
maillant voix et 5 maintenant il va
envoyer le pion à il prend h
la raison c'est juste comme il l'a fait
à cinq je m'attendais pas à ce qu'ils
prennent h maintenant du coup ils rasent
j'ai mes mains il suit plus que
d'envoyer le pion la case des 8es
contrôler la tour est cloué les blancs
ne peuvent plus rien faire c'est fini
tam conduite c'est foutu bon alors juste
pour dire ce qui s'est passé dans cette
partie la grosse erreur déjà c'est
d'avoir pris en d4 pour pour les noirs
bon là il n'y a pas eu cinq de jouer
mais admettons il a mille fois angers 5
je suis pas forcément fan en fait de
faire ce fou angers 5e quand il fait g4
ici dans cette situation là son idée
c'est fou et 3 et g5 maintenant donc il
aurait pu prendre aucun risque se
développer en eux trois et jouer le même
type de position
sauf qu'il aurait pu faire g5 plus
facilement vers ces rajouts si ce qui
l'a aidé mais géré par là que le fou
angers 5 ans fait du coup il a été voué
à bouger une deuxième fois parce qu' ils
obstruent elle a poussé g5 d'accord mais
là en fait faut pas avoir peur c'est pas
parce qu'on pousse sur votre roi qu'il
faut ne pas manger les pions qui avance
ok il ya le roi en c1 je suis d'accord
l'euro en c1 il pas il peut être en
danger
in fine est mais je vois pas l'intérêt
de ne pas manger le pion b5
en fait parce que l'attak
déjà je gagne un tempo sur la dalle il
va devoir bouger saddam je vais faire g5
et il va voir ça il va lui falloir
encore trois coups pour pouvoir jouer
sur ma colonne b et moi je suis déjà à
deux trois coups de maths en fait je
suis tellement proches de maths que je
pense qu'il aura même pas le temps de
les jouer ses trois coups et ça c'est
quand même assez important je dirais
dans l'esprit quoi ce qu'en laissant le
pion en vie en fait ils pouvaient se
prendre b4 et ça c'était beaucoup plus
dangereux le pion menace le cavalier sur
fou prend dé 7,6 a pu en france et 3 et
si on bouge lecavalier il peut déjà
peut-être prendre en d5 ou peut-être
prendre avec le cavalier moi j'en sais
rien
à
il reprend amené la dame en a quatre et
commencé à faire des trucs en réalité
les noirs vont être plus menaçant de
cette manière là roye b un c4 est là
déjà il ya peut-être c3 qui arrive on
est encore flou des quatre et ça va pour
les blancs probablement mais je veux
dire par là que en fait prendre le pion
en bessin que c'est pas toujours mauvais
comme des pions qui avance devant votre
watts et parfois faut simplement les
prendrai comme ça ça évite d'avoir des
ruptures j'ai passé quelque chose que
vous maîtrisez les gars ou pas ça
donc
on va aller voir la prochaine partie
avoir des joueurs un peu plus fort 2000
contre 2000 et quelques contres 2003
française avant d'échanger réussir et
son cavalier e 5 rapidement sa gérance
est une bonne nouvelle pour les blancs
il gagne la paire de fouet il installe
un pion au 5 mai les noirs ont peut-être
une idée voilà ça c'est vraiment super
bien passé pour les blancs la structure
est bonne il ya les pions qui arrive
arrive 5ème si c'est un peu comme dans
une écossaise d'ailleurs faut qu'il va
venir en d3 la case et 6 pour le cavale
la l'ouverture c'est vraiment mal placé
de mal passer pour les noirs voilà
avancer un peu vite mais bon peut on
peut la refaire donc c'est une variante
des changes ça jusque là on va passer
vite kf3 foulée 6 et 4 c6 qui haïssez 3
et 7 x 2 alors est ce que là l'idée
c'est pas plutôt de prendre ces quatre
et de jouer contre le pion isolé
peut-être je sais pas si le cas est
vraiment mis en place en 1 7 6 avec
cavalier seul je trouve que ça n'a pas
trop ensemble tu fais plutôt à chis avec
le cavagnan f6 quand tu as peur du coup
à chf ou g5
mais là en fait tache 6,5 ou
prophylactiques contre quoi sur fou j'ai
cinq de toute façon on veut jouer f6
donc en est à cavalier c'est thq si ça
n'a pas l'air d'aller ensemble rock rock
cavalier e 5 l'appareil prendront eux 5
j'avais quand même plutôt fait cavalier
17 quoi pour essayer de chasser le
cavalier
les blancs ont poussé il a fait f5 donc
ça c'est l'idée typique 1 pour faire f
si c'est cassé c'est bien joué
m6 est fou et 7 très bien joué fou à vii
parce que surtout reprend il ya
cavaliers prend roi prend et e6 échec
fourchette
donc ça m'a l'air sympa fou avec ses 3
je suis de 6 oui c'est plutôt bien joué
mais là peut-être qui peut faire fou
prend h6 tu en prends un fils et d'un
mach 4 ça marche peut-être mais après tu
peux juste faire d'un match 4 laisser
dame prend des six bon tu sais pas
c'était trop risqué de faire ça quand
même
on sait jamais peut-être f4 échec leur
tour fait genre de choses mais c'est
peut-être pas nécessaire de risques et
il a fait d'un match 4 partout avec les
noirs tu prends je sais pas si c'est
nécessaire d'aller prendre ce risque
ok là on a dit kai pro f c'est toi les
servantes qu'on avait vu fouet f4
cavaliers à j-6 du coup seul coup il ya
fou prend des six ouais donc savante
qu'on avait vu et ça marche
là faut juste voir pions quand même cet
échec intermédiaires qui est fait il
faut prendre des six
voilà ces dames de plus contre une pièce
et ouverture ratée par le joueur noir et
victoire tranquille des blancs on va
voir la partie suivante des quatre caves
6.466 croix rouge et 7 fou de rock g4
away
ouais alors c'est ça se tente mais mais
bon là le problème c'est que j'ai 4 h 4
en gros ça sert à rien c'est une attaque
pipeau quoi n'y a pas d' attaque il
arriva il va juste se faire échanger
voir le cahier qui va arriver à eux
quatre et concrètement ça se passe ça se
passe mal en fait c'est pas énorme
intérêt de jouer comme ça avec avec les
blancs ça pas énormes intérêts il va
juste perdre ses pions et il a pas il a
pas d'attaquant en réalité donc non je
dirais plutôt plutôt une mauvaise partie
de la part des blancs g4 h4 vous pouvez
le faire mais bon je peux vous montrer
un truc j'ai une idée que je peux vous
montrer à au cas où vous voulez jouer un
truc très agressif je pourrais vous
faire des vidéos dessus si vous
souhaitez peut-être mais assez de faire
des quatre cavaliers f6 cegeka direct ok
ça ça se joue en fait sur kai prend 1,4
tu t'en prends en aux cavaliers tu
gagnes le centre bon c'est un peu
mauvais mais c'est agressif et ça peut
jouer mais ce qu'il a fait lors le
système de londres le truc si tu veux
attaquer à les droits ici tu as besoin
de dan des deux fois 6 mais en réalité
si là le truc c'est qu'il ya le fury 3
qui va obstrué donc ton attaque avec les
blancs elle va elle va battre de l aile
quoi rafa est peut-être temps tg5 par
contre cavale et h5 pas possible ils
bougent le cavalier h4 hockey qui
taillent allez y allez quoi même si même
si tu fais h5 à la rigueur même si les
noirs jouable jour rien d'impressionnant
bon c'est pas vraiment pas
impressionnant de faire ça mais en fait
même là j'ai du mal à voir comment tu
mates
moi j'ai donné des coups et le cavalier
va revenir en russie ce tour 8,3 je suis
ton monte a du mal à passer le fou mais
encore mais là comme ça s'est passé dans
la partie avec h4 et ouais ça n'a pas du
tout fonctionné non on fait une petite
série de coups bizarre mais bon ça
suffit largement en fait il n'y a pas d'
attaque vient juste un pion de moi
tu pas si ça vous plaît comme format
n'hésitez pas à réagir dans le tchat
après si je n'en ferais comme ça c'est
pas forcément votre préférée mais c'est
pour changer un peu ce qui est un
bouquin pour avoir des bases théoriques
des bases théoriques en finale mais pour
commencer j'ai fait sur mon site toutes
et tous des petits articles pour ça et
peut-être des gens qui peuvent mettre
des liens là dans le chatt haussier donc
on a cette finale qui est assez logique
d'être entré en cette finale finalement
ont vu de la partie on va voir s'il est
noir réussissent à
à enchaîner alors la casse pour le roi
ce serait laquelle d'après vous sur
quelques asie doit aller ce roi d'après
vous sur quel casse va le roi
question que je pose au chat je vous
laisse y réfléchir f5 exactement sur
wave assure la case f5 lecavalier il se
prend une focale du fou et la tour peut
pas vraiment attaqué sur la cinquième
donc le roi blanc f5 et ici il arrive au
f5 ça va être un vrai problème
donc il va falloir réagir et que
cavalier il vend des deux mois j'aurais
peut-être remis en d3 le cavale mais je
sais pas vraiment pourquoi faire
maintenant qu'est ce qu'on voit jouer
ici très haut noir c'est bien là pas
jouer le bon coup du coup ça laisse le
le coup à jouer autour des quatre
exactement et on va collecter collecter
le pion et après on envoie j'ai ça gagne
tout seul le cavalier mal placé il en
diagonale par rapport aux pions là il
est en train de s'embêter à jouer du
côté de sa minorité de s'affaiblir les
pions regardez bien ce qu'il a fait il
pouvait mettre s'il voulait le pion à à
5 et faire une structure où enfin je
n'aurais pas toucher 1 mais où un pion
défendent et tous les autres et ce qu'il
vient de faire avec ces deux derniers
coups de pions c'est d'affaiblir tous
ses pions ce qui fait que si un jour les
blancs trouve du con tre jeu en trois
coups ils ont rasé les trois pions alors
que dans la stratégie avec cette
structure là c'est cette baie 6 à 5 ça
n'arrivait pas du tout est là du coup
qu'est ce qui va se passer y percer 6
mais c'est normal et l' hyper f6 pains
géré par la ce et j'y peux rien quoi
mais c'est la stratégie de merde qu'il a
fait ça lui coûte la partie en réalité
car de thé pions commisson c'était très
bien et tu préfinancer bien tu es puni à
cause de ta structure pour y passer tant
mieux c'est bien fait pour lui il s'est
compliqué la vie est hyper à cause de ça
eh ben c'est bien jouer qui est rangée 5
3 des 4 et on a des saint pierrois c6
non mais gers et cgc son erreur
stratégique qui le fait perdre sa partie
un joueur belge contre un joueur
français
non mais c'est dommage en fait pour matt
smith qu'il a bien joué la partie et
tout d'un coup c'est n'importe quoi de
faire ça les mecs vous pouvez pas faire
à chaque fois h4d qu'un mec fait grand
roque avec votre fou en c1 et votre
d'amendé 1 quoi s'agir soyez sérieux je
vais aux échecs normaux non mais juste
tu peux pas attaquer quand à trois
pièces à l'écurie quatre pièces à
l'écurie géré quand bien même tu prends
y prends mais tu as tenté f4 et essayer
une attaque mais ces petits pots fait
mettre le foin f5 n'a pas assez de
pièces qui convergent mais regardez les
pièces à l'attaqué il y en a à peine une
et les noirs ils sont blindés avec
influent qu'eto'o est un cavalier prend
2 avec ce qui est aussi possible dans
cette position même si normalement on
reprend du centre ce qui veut tout façon
jeu pour cinq et il souffre la colonne
est faillible inde le roi mais là en
gros les blancs ils ont ils ont rien
fait ils ont juste perdu le centre
ça mais c'est un peu dommage faudrait
que j'aie divise les attaques
hypothéquerait non mais c'est un petit
peu dommage c'est un petit peu dommage
honnêtement c'est c'est un peu moche
quoi c'est pas gravissime a mais le truc
c'est qu'ils développent jamais ces
pièces j'ai pas vous faites ça escape
je comprends pas en fait pourquoi vous
faites ça il a le droit à mordelles unis
françois jacq
ouais non mais c'est sûr qu'il a le
droit mais bon après c'est pas c'est pas
assez pas perdu encore man ans
c'est pour ça que c'était pas mal joué
fou rire la colonnade vrai mais écoutez
quand on en est là moi j'ai une partie
complètement pourri dans cette position
mais au pire tu fais ça tu fais b3 fou
b2c 4 si tu veux jouer un truc solide et
aura le temps d'attaquer tu fais un
système comme si tu veux jouer l attaque
comme je vous dis des quatre il a fait
cavalier 6 beams g4 direct si vous
voulez vraiment jouer du n'importe quoi
a fait du n'importe quoi plus rapidement
quoi fait du n'importe quoi qui compte
fait du n'importe quoi qui se joue fait
pas du n'importe quoi qui fait rien quoi
nez dessus des 4 qui a eu 6 g 400 voix
et tu vas faire g5 est ok il prend tu
veux 4 elle a au moins tu as une partie
ouverte
disons que vous faites n'importe quoi
faites le avec conviction fait une
grotte à la rigueur c'est moins bête en
fait du n'importe quoi cohérent loch
ness
non mais venez nombreux avec conviction
enfin des catia v6 g4 kaboom d'envoi
quoi t'en vois vraiment pour de vrai
sans voix pour de vrai voilà damev de
c'est bien un joueur qui a peut-être un
truc jolie lassé de faire d'armes
français trois tours en d2 tour des huit
dames c'est 2 fois 6 tu gagnes sur le
clouage fait autour des 8 bon c'est plus
fort mais moi je j'avais le petit côté
exotique et là bien évidemment très bon
tour prend sa voiture prend ça gagne
dame b 8 x fuite et d'amr matteau
prochain bon elle a du coup fait si tu
es parti pour ça maintenant tu fais
peut-être d'amd bon quoique d'amener un
roi de mon nom ça va ouais ça la mode
d'envoyer les pions h rapidement ce
moment c'est pour ça que j'essaye de
vous calmer un petit peu tous avec sa
faux le faire dans des situations et là
un petit conseil dans les situations
bien clair fait toujours gaffe aux maths
du couloir
parce que quand il ya la dame qui arrive
si vous devez faire flouer fuite ça fait
damer fuite maths ça peut ne pas être
idiot de faire un petit coup de hache
cinq histoires deux bonds à la dame des
cinq très bien joué ça c'est bien ils
échangent les dames et c'est fini bon le
h4 un peu tôt je re montre pour ceux qui
n'étaient pas là encore une idée si vous
voulez si vous avez décidé de faire de
la merde dans votre parti est d'envoyer
du jeu jouer une ouverture qui envoient
des quatre caves si j'ai quatre bim
on en voit après quand tu fais que ça
avait que 3 c'est ce qu'on appelle le
système cole c'est un système de
retraités genre moi je joue je joue ça
parfois parce que je suis un papy du
dimanche
si vous jouez un système de papier du
dimanche joué comme des papys du
dimanche vous inventez pas à une des
ouvertures ne me fait pas h 4 si vous
voulez jouer agressif ici c'est plutôt
b4 le coup peut-être pour faire flamber
deux c4 un jour et prendre le centre
genre il fait des 5 vous faites rock
il fait ses six où je vais peut-être
avec ses 4 que vous voulez gagner du
temps sur l'ale dams assez agressif ça
si vous voulez jouer agressif b4 pouvait
être une option ici bas c'est un peu
moderne comme manière de jouer enfin
saisi d'un peu moderne mais ça pouvait
être une idée pour jouer agressif mais
tu a bloqué toutes tes pièces la tat
bloqué ton jeu allèles dame tata
structure de pions pointe vers les dames
et on sait que c'est important de voir
les choses pointe et quand ça pointe
généralement une peu il peut y avoir il
peut y avoir match et là il ya match
aller à dame complètement le match se
joue ici
il se joue pas de l'autre côté et le fou
on voit bien qu'ils participent pas au
jeu donc bon voilà pour cette partie ii
et i du prime alors on va regarder on va
aller on va se faire plein en suivant un
petit peu crypte talent bon joueur il a
tenté de maths a tenté un piège
vous remonterez peut-être après alors
structure karo kann côté d'atopie nous
et pour le moment ça apparaisse au
leader qui est des cinq pas toujours bon
parfois on peut commencer par h6 ici et
faire dame c'est set décisif où bessette
et grand roque dans ces structures karo
kann je sais pas si vous connaissez et
après jouer avec les fous et faire g5 g4
parfois on peut un peu temporisé jusqu'à
le truc c'est que son cavalier voir ce
qui s'est passé c'est que son cavalier
l'aimions dessin quillan ils font un f6
pour défendre g7 et maintenant il se
fait chasser ça va commencer à être
désagréable peut-être
valeo cède donc il est en train de
partir de cette famille de gaz ça ferait
que je refasse une nouvelle master class
sur les positions de type karo kann tas
dans le futur les choses contrat avec
favon le alors on la refera bien
maintenant peut-être très problème c'est
que lecavalier il serait mieux f8 ici
c'est difficile pour les noirs donc f5
c'est peut-être pas mal joué mais c'est
pas les cas ce que tu veux avoir le
ballon mais kg 5 c'est bien joué par une
question et non frange de 5 francs g5 le
raf si j'aime pas trop s'affaiblit sur
casse blanche mais bon pourquoi pas aux
noms propres en 1 h 6 c'est dommage
parce qu'il fait trois sets c'est être
pas si clair cette structure là n'est
pas si mauvaise en réalité on est
peut-être d'etam f4 ou quoi mais il
aurait aussi pu jouer juste avec g6
pouvait être aussi une idée mais bon âge
6-3 7-6 pouvait aller en vrai c'est
dommage genre les espions
or et c'est dommage
j'ai bien aimé tour 4 par contre ils
s'activent tue pas une mauvaise partie
auto pilot franchement on voit que les
joueurs élèvent leur niveau de juin
quand ils jouent contre plus fort qu'eux
topi nous qui élève son niveau de jeu et
ça fait plaisir aux la lavande
je pense qu'à un peu compris cette
partie c'était pas mal baissé d'un peu
changé les joueurs parce que sinon
retombe toujours sur les mêmes
on va regarder une finale puis ça nous
permettra de reprendre des joueurs alors
cette finale de dame si la dame blanche
arrivants bessette elle va être pénible
savard par ressembler à partie deux
joues à une joute contre grillage qui
n'a qu'on a fait sur la chaîne ya
quelques jours mais le truc c'est
qu'elle n'y arrive pas parce que les
noirs ont mis leur d'avancé 8 en premier
et il n'y a pas de plan non il n'ya pas
de téléportation possible parce qu'elle
puy-en-velay si ce qui bloque donc c'est
complètement nul on va regarder un peu
comment ça se fait
on va voir
b4 aa intéressant il joue sur le fait
que les noirs
alors je sais pas pourquoi il a joué
avec 6 dans les finales de deux dames il
faut bien protéger son roi et si si il
s'ouvre le roi en fait c'est assez
bizarre et b4 c'est très bien joué de la
part des blancs parce qu'il veut sur
pions prend 3 bougez à ces cinq pardon
roi bouge plus on prend puis on prend et
à 7
donc c'est assez bien joué ça fait
plaisir
ouais et maintenant il va faire d'un f3
dame b cette dame le cadre d'un bébé
sept arrêts clés noires veut faire
ramener le roi des 8
parce que si le roi étant des huit ont
menacera dame prend bessette ab et roy
machin et la dame b c'est très fort
direct s'il a vu la vidéo il le fait ça
a bien joué alors la main fait roi 8
dames 17,3 des huit pour pour menacer
dame prend pions prend aux ac 7 et ça
doit tenir mais bon là il se prend à
matt après réussissent d'amd 5 ça c'est
quand même gênant 1 mais je pense que si
fait roi de 8
donc ils menacent pas dame prend pions
prendre ce qu'adam au prochain mais
genre si tu fais à béton tu vas active
et hongrois tu fais genre
j'ai trois pour faire croire la dame
décès 3g 2 3 des 8 et là on me menace de
chasser la dame et ça doit toujours être
nul je pense bon alors lis des avantages
blanc c'est évident les blancs vont
tourner ils vont faire dame 4 et ils
vont être pénibles un peu comme dans la
partie garage qui mit à jouer jun mais
c'était important de ramener le roi et
la dame là-bas bond intéressant
intéressant du coup ça va nous permettre
de voir vers de terre devant vers de
terre donc c'est une carotte énorme
davance ouais bon pourquoi pas
un parti me paraît pas excellentes mais
bon on va pas revenir forcément dessus
avec 4 c'est pas assez intéressant à
quaëdypre réussissent beaucoup d'erreurs
tactiques
ça joue pas si mal il ya trop d'erreurs
tactiques et ouais
voyez un peu de tout en fait il ya la
tour qui tombe ya tout qui tombe va
peut-être passer une autre partie saleh
était pas oh la la
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi pas juste
prendre du matériel auquel et peur de ça
ok mais je rebondis et j'attaque là il
prend je prends et ce à la fin du bal
qu'on compte les musiciens et puis là
les musiciens et y en a un petit peu
plus côté blancois les joueurs de
trompettes sont là c'est dommage c'est
dommage ça qui est produite qui prend
déjà être bon faut toujours regarder les
rebonds avec les cavaliers faut toujours
regarder les rebonds olala il se prend
normes et c'est mérité
en vrai c'est mérité il s'est fait punir
regardez toujours les rebonds de vaud
cavaliers parce que là par exemple le
rebond est fluide 17 b6 je sais pas moi
je le connais par coeur j'ai
l'impression vu le nombre de fois que je
les fais suis là pour à les retoucher
une dame là bas
je pense de la compet de puzzle rage sur
proust il nous a tu vas être étonné de
mon avis je trouve ça inintéressant je
vois pas l'intérêt mais après si les
gens aiment bien fois tu vois s'il ya
plus de choses pourquoi pas là il faut
qu'ils tendent cavalli g5 après ok tu
dois tenter ça t'es obligé de tenter en
fait c'est ton seul piège tu as une
seule vie est à une idée assez marrante
section h six as tu peux faire kg 6 et
cavaliers cet essai un perpète
ok allez les mecs il a qu'une vie vers
de terre à une seule vie il a le père
pète non vers de terre vers de terre ou
alors qu'est ce qui m'a fait vers de
terre quand ils auraient pu faire un
père pète de génie il aurait pu faire
tout avec huit tours prend la fuite
cavaliers g63 roi g8 qui a valu à ces
trois jeux suite cavaliers g6 non il
avait un piège dans la partie la rater o
le ver de terre
ah c'est dommage il avait une vie quoi
j'y crois pas j'y crois pas ah je suis
deg pour lui a il était jolie le père
pète ça lui aurait fait place de le
faire les joueurs de ce niveau là en
général ils sont heureux de faire ce
genre de père pète parce qu'ils n'ont
jamais fait d'aussi beau et ça leur
laisse un beau souvenir quoi il le
raconte le lendemain quand ils arrivent
au club d'échecs au boulot quand ils en
parlent à leur boulot généralement n'y a
pas grand monde qui s'y intéressent mais
bon ils sont calmes heureux quoi
kroll a là un seul piège une vie quoi il
a vécu une ville avec une balle il a
raté grâce à ces comme un mario quand
des fois il te reste une vie et tu rates
un saut hyper facile quoi c'est dommage
ça aurait laissé un bon souvenir
bon alors une autre partie à une petite
ce qu'en dit heinz candidate des huit
tours à vide n'était pas obligatoire
mais non mais bon t'as est loin de le
faire crème tour f8 pour troll
en tout cas oui ce genre de j'aurais
j'aurais fier la tour quoi c'est sympa
bon ça généralement ça apporte rien de
faire des cinq ici normalement tu veux
plutôt joué pour four b3 et c4 si tu
veux surprendre un peu le centre quand
tu fais des singles le truc c'est qu'il
ya tout qui va s'échanger massivement et
il va y avoir c'est cissé il ya toutes
les pièces noires qui vont se développer
ça sert à rien c'est pas un pion isolé
un en d4 the wheel coco l'asticot kenny
merci quai pour ton cours sur les
finales de foot couleurs opposées je
suis débutant et sa appris plein de
choses restent franchement cela mon
cours il n'a pas eu le succès qu'ils
méritent et sur youtube secours c'est ce
et c'est du contenu vraiment très
qualitatif qui honnêtement pourrait très
bien enfin çà çà çà çà va ressembler un
peu dans l'esprit à ce qu'on va faire
quand on fera du contenu payant
jusque là comme on était un peu en
galère de contenu j'ai décidé de faire
un truc bien membré c'est toujours un
peu triste de voir que c'est pas
forcément le contenu qui qui marche le
mieux
bon avec les blancs il a fait ce dessin
est prématuré salut à tuer tout son
avantage
en réalité quand il a fait des cinq
regardez bien il a échangé lui contre
lui si on réfléchit
vrai ou faux
ça n'a pas grand intérêt
là il a peut-être un truc marrant mais
ça marche pas c'était de faire f 4 mai à
foug des quatre échecs faut toujours
faire gaffe à ce genre d'idées s'est
très vite arriver ça bon il a peut-être
eu mais il faut des quatre échecs psycho
au roulement de tambour non psycho
oh non je vérifie alors dit si ça a
marché le g4 f5 le classique
oh ça a marché pourquoi tu fais ça
psycho un an et maintenant sur g4 il ya
un f6 le train ne passe pas deux fois
psycho
bon allez il ya quand même qui a valu au
cices encore il va y aller une calloc'h
les mecs dites-moi sérieusement vous
avez été déçu plus que psycho leurs
atouts vous en foutez quand les mecs
rate là il y avait une surprise et un
mec à 2100 il ya un mec à 2100
financièrement ça au nom arrêter ça
alors pour être des cieux est mais là le
g4 est sain qu'il avait bon est ce que
vous pensez qu'il l'aï la gagne cette
finale ou pas au final il a une finale
correct après l'accueil des cats et
pénible elle est déjà pas facile
- elle est déjà papa elle est pas facile
elle est plus facile parce qui perd un
pion et quand tu perds un pion
têtu commence déjà à être mal tu
commence déjà à être mal
ok sa chance et que l'autre à mailhac et
prend b3 peut-être foutront b6 cb tout
reprendre mais celle qui a essayé 5 et
ya tout reprend à sept points à quatre
pour prend à 8
ça va notez pas tomber dans le piège
tu es là sa tourelle et mal
tour 17 il faut prendre trois tours eu 6
3 f 16 f 5 g fgf et les noires
s'activent mais sait il est peut-être
même plus mieux ohlala il avait filé le
calbute et après foot français c'est tu
regardes de l'adversaire b6 énorme gaffe
fallait faire à 6 ou cavaliers c'est si
soudain porte b s'il vous prend b6 il
est de retour
ok maintenant fou prend 1,7 et la
mobylette b à ses chaussettes partie
chez un psychologue il est là
très haut blanc comment vous gagnez
l'élite très haut blanc comment gagne ça
il ya un coût qui fait très mal ici
l'élite fouet trois abandons menace
menace menace seul coup pour pas perdre
de matériel tout reprend qui on prend
mobylette mobylette au lieu de b6
comment vous gagnez ça les amis très
haut blanc b3 la tour est protégée en
chasse cavaliers bouge pour recouvrir sa
même idée gagner allez c'est un
adversaire a oublié de mettre la tour
sur b il fallait peut-être à l'e3 je
sais pas aller 3 6 4
oui petit il a oublié d'aller chercher
le pion nassirou qu 3b tron non non non
non non la la technique c'est de faire
roi ses trois tours à trois rois b2 pour
pas pouvoir se faire prendre par
derrière ou il va se faire prendre
âgé que je peux dire un truc qu il va se
faire prendre en et vous pouvez finir la
phrase vous même
oh non
rome il va quand même la gagner parce
que son adversaire a laissé le voir
revenir à la partie
la gagne et je suis pas je suis stressé
l'a esquissé gagner ça votre avis alors
il a gagné
quelles parties de dengue petit
sicilienne
c'était sympa comme partie à une petite
nana jorf là on accroche asig
c'était une victoire 10 ennemis cinq et
demi l'équipe adverse a été valeureuse
et on a on a gagné grâce à une
défaillance de john williams heures qui
à leur première échiquier qui a réalisé
le score de 1 2 me sur quatrième et donc
il ya qui a été complètement défaillant
et qui nous a permis de l'emporter
bon sang voit le jeu mais là ça m'a
l'air de l'attak a l'air beaucoup plus
forte pour les noirs il ya quatre baies
3 qui va arriver
est ce qu'il ya des gros tournois en ce
moment il ya mike enzi qu'un très gros
tournois
qui est un très très gros tournois
tu as une position mais avec avec les
blancs et je conseille plutôt de jouer
vente avec petit rock contre la contre
la nage d'offres rails nous ont fait mal
hein
pour retourner à mes bons contacts guy
caruana futur candidat qui joue pas plus
sérieux que ça c'est relou c'est normal
proust hinault c'est exactement un atp
250 avant un grand chelem c'est rarement
djoko et nadal qui les gagnants tu peux
pas jouer sérieux tu es en phase
d'entraînement tu es en train de te
chauffer tu peux pas jouer ça à fond
c'est tout à fait normal
bref heroes jack dû pas mal hein j'ai
ouvert mon avis va rapidement rentrer
dans le top 15 mondial
après on verra alors qu'ils mènent pas
vraiment bien leur attaque mais bon
c'est un peu un peu compliqué à
expliquer c'est que des variantes
tactiques donc là ça en réalité le
format de la vidéo ne s'y prête pas trop
sur une vingtaine de futurs championnats
est ce que ça va être le prochain
champion du monde ça je suis pas sur mes
futurs champions du monde oui parce que
carl scène depuis qu'il a un peu perdu
l'avantagé qu'il avait pris grâce à
alpha 0 en l'ayant avant les autres
depuis que cet avantage là abc enfin mon
avis en tout cas il ya eu cet avantage
là on va pas revenir des psycho
puisqu'il est admis en sueur j'ai
l'impression que les autres ont un peu
on peut fermer le gap
depuis donc une éco sel
jamais vu cette variante mais peut-être
ça joue
donc est ce que j'ai amené sur youtube à
partir ou jacques guéry n'en était pas
une belle partie en vrai trop d'erreurs
trop d'erreurs il ya des parties plus
plus joli que ça allait beaucoup
d'erreurs jeu pendant cette partie
donc
mais à plein des finales furent oui bon
il ya une finale de pions mais déjà les
pas si compliqué que ça c'est surtout du
calcul et en plus c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas une super partie je préfère
quand c'est comme ça je préfère regarder
des vieilles montres et des vieilles
parties sympa demain je crois qu'on va
sortir
c'est pas que je crois c'est que je sais
que demain c'est la vidéo sur la partie
karpov une zik air qui va sortir ça
paraît quand même plus intéressant que
fuir ou de jacques guéry déjà ça va vous
apprendre quelque chose c'est une partie
qu'il faut que tout le monde connaisse
c'est guéri qui fait une blondeur dans
la finale deux tours est avancé firoud
déjà qui joue mal et après c'est l'autre
qui blender enfin il ya beaucoup
d'erreurs
c'est pas en soi ce pas une très
mauvaise passe est pas vraiment une très
mauvaise partie mais c'est pour la
partie bon là c'est nul c'est égal c'est
égal ségala blender la blender bon alors
là ça me fait mal aux yeux
pourquoi tu fais c'est prend toujours
reprendre vers le centre safia une vraie
raison pourquoi reprendre de ses lattes
à un pion qui est qui arriérés isolé fac
est juste isolés que tu vas pouvoir
bloquer et peut-être créer un clouage
bon enfant que tu vas pas y arriver si
le mec vous bien mais tu vas essayer et
là tu fais c b et tutus carrément ton
c'est dommage
faire la vidéo que de la finale de pions
et la vie est revenue à 3 4 minutes mais
je suis pas sûr faire les gens n'aiment
pas ce genre de contenu donc on ne le
fait pas à la partie celle le faut à 7
ou à gala coneway la fameuse partie car
pour vous les ignorez tout à fait aux
biscuits rld
donc du coup de m'en sortir à ça demain
sortira ça ça me paraît plus intéressant
de voir karpov une easycare que fier ou
déjà guéri quoi
à
[Musique]
quand est-ce qu'on reprend un service
sûr kasparov
quand on voit les séries payante sur les
joueurs n'ont peut-être jamais mais
peut-être dans quelques années tout l on
sortira un épisode mais sinon un an
bon peut-être ton ces deux et maintenant
voici 6 cd 5 qui arrive
et peut-être la finale de fil rouge à ge
pour l affaire dans une si je fais une
sélection des trucs de janvier je
pourrais mettre la finale de fuir ou dja
c'est dommage que je n'ai pas préparé
j'ai oublié mais j'ai eu un petit coup
de fatigue ou 3e set c'est horrible
vercamer sur la vidéo de mysore à 10
heures je crois qu'on a tous un peu
perdu la concentration sur les parties
du tournoi un peu en freestyle il reste
10 minutes de tournoi c'est normal après
un jeu nous au toit plus haut dit ça on
va voir s'il a gagné sa finale de pions
parce qu'elle est peut-être pas si
simple ya quand même des pions doublé
mais c'est pas sûr qu'il puisse créer un
pion pas assez de ce côté là sur un truc
face b 5 breaks face b 5 à 5 f 5 3 6 3
la roi prend roi prend walla walla roi
prend roi prend roi la voilà roy prend
pouss pouss pouss pouss pouss pouss et
gagne
besson lui faire à bab à oui mais là il
ya beaucoup d'attentes aussi aux qu'est
ce qui peut faire ses juges ou et b3 ici
je suis un peu débile je calcule et le
truc ce que je sentais que ça gagner
mais b3 c'est quand même plus simple
coup d'attentes le roi noir jouer roi
des cinq après laférois des cinq direct
c'est une petite faute fallait faire le
coup d'attendre parce que là c'est la
rente qu'on a joué pour avoir la même
avec un temps de plus terre avoir encore
le trait voir prendre ça après c'est pas
très dur à gagner mais il va encore
falloir s'appliquer
donc
c'est marrant de voir si la gagne qu'est
ce qui va supérieur de palans des 5
il faut pas qu'ils se mettent sur la
sixième pour pas se prendre un intrus
poquet je conseillerais de tenter
d'amener un banal problème c'est qu'ils
provoquent la poussée du pion
ont-elles pu remonter le plus remonté le
pion je pense que si mais la dame en c6
et le rang à six il ya plus des chèques
pour les noirs pourra faire à 5 b 6 à 7
3 à 7 de manière assez sécurisé
y a plus vraiment des chèques côté noir
et ça va gagner tout seul
la b6 bessette b6 bessette
par contre qu'on fera sion je sais pas
si vous savez quel jour c'est j'avais
envie de faire en direct la partie
firouz jacques hansen et après de faire
un petit un petit résumé mais c'est pas
du tout ça et quelques jours sa tombe
j'arrive pas à trouver malheureusement
mal heureusement j'arrive pas à trouver
le vin lundi donc vous êtes sûr où vous
pensez bien jouer dame cesser at il
forcé change des dames
et ça c'est sympa comme ça peut-être pas
être une super partie mais c'est sympa
un premier ils se sont déjà joints en
langue j'ai pas l'impression qu'ils sont
jouant longue
c'est peut être le premier duel d'une
longue décennie là qui arrive ça peut
être le duel de 2020 2030 fil rouge à
karlstad
certains vendent des changes à ça peut
être le
des combats combat qui va durer une
décennie et ça peut être sympa de deux
morts ils sont pas joints aux longues
je pense pas que ça je vois bien prendre
sa retraite si tu tombes du trop
horrible c'était être fier roja qui va
lui prendre son trône tout cas ça peut
être le combat 2020 2024
ça peut être le combat on admettant qu'
en 2022 fier au jaï aux candidats qui
les gagne pas qu'il y retourne en 2024
que soient toujours karl scène sur le
trône 2024 ça peut être le gros match
car le sel firoud déjà que tout le monde
attend fondamentalement
hardy vous dites j'ai bien envie de
suivre ça en live
si on répète cela trois engagements
mvele encore un peu au dessus mais
peut-être pas pour longtemps
je sais pas si vous qui faites vous
faire ça moi je trouve que c'est sympa
mais après ce genre de partie que tu as
envie de voir quand même en direct ça
peut se voir là ça peut être la première
d'une longue série
je pense c'est sympa de la suivre au
prochain puisque jouant de façon c'est
ma chaîne en même temps en même temps
mais wen ont jusqu à 9 c il faudra voir
les images et non pas ce que je vais
faire sur ma chaîne perso donc j'aurai
pas les images cyril mais bon les images
honnêtement
c'est pas ça qui fait le jeu décisif
surtout que pour avoir un peu regardé
les images prouvent pas que ce soit
super bien filmé honnêtement ce que
damas prendrait quatre est jouable est
probablement de toute façon la structure
noir est bien plus avantageuses y siens
avec le pion pas ses protégés et dame
prend des cas doit maintenant aussi un
je pense un impact probable que dans
l'intervalle ce point comme à nant au
contraire le gars qui s'occupe de la
ligue qui s'occupe des relations avec
les joueurs pros avec les managers de la
ligue m'a dit qu'ils avaient pas assez
de bons managers comme moi allez bon
est-ce que je signerais pour la saison
prochaine en pro de chasse ligue non tu
vu avec le canada tire est je veux dire
après s'ils m'appellent et kim dickens
je joue avec la france parce que je me
sens français et que ça me fait plaisir
de jouer avec les codes français oui
mais mais sinon tu restes avec son
équipe des duchesses bras quoi voilà
peut-être tout reprend dé 5,2 me prends
des as
c'est marrant ça marche pas parce qu'il
ya un match du pouvoir à la fin tu as
voulu jouer avec les bras depuis reste
on verra mais on va pas le payer en plus
donc ça m'étonnerait qu'ils viennent
jouer avec nous mais bon on reste on
reste des trolls jusqu'au bout on a su
main
il joue pour les pieds et des mains pour
les bras qui a fait un bon tournoi
bravo à toi et à le pion c'est qu'il va
partir à un moment donné ça va faire mal
hein
ce qu'il veut si vous jouez avec les
bras moi je lui en veux pas mais bon on
va pas on va pas faire des pieds et des
mains pour le récupérer
est-ce qu'on contre ux et les agents
libres en équipe de france non on n'a
pas besoin
on n'a pas besoin mort après c'est
dommage qu'il n'ait pas voulu jouer avec
nous mais bon c'est son droit le plus
fondamental y avait 5 1 quand même
fourchette quand même c'est toujours
pareil tu avais demandé oui je crois que
j'avais je lui avais écrit ouais ouais
je lui ai écrit m'a pas répondu
c'est pas grave enfin il fait ce qu'il
veut un passé ça l'est tuant lui en veut
pas on lui en veut pas
je vois retour c8 et le pion il va à mon
avis va faire mal un rang des quatre
tours d1
je crois qu'il ya un joli thème ici çà
çà çà çà çà non ça marche pas non çà çà
çà çà çà çà çà et sa vue sans ordi avec
tout achat mater en ce sens l'âme après
je me suis interverti
après fait ce qu'il veut a legacy
ferroudja il veut jouer avec nous ils
jouent avec nous si vous jouez avec les
bras il joue avec les bras enfin y'a pas
de soucis après un bon vivre dans un
pays de jouer avec l'équipe du pays mais
bon après chacun fait ce qu'il veut
chacun fait ce qu'il veut il n'y a pas
de n'y a pas une règle que pour devenir
français il faut il faut avoir envie de
jouer avec les trucs français surtout en
pro che slick tu vois il ya personne qui
claudie temps c'est une règle
fondamentale la république française que
oui joue en pro chess ligue avec
l'équipe de france est une obligation
il a le droit il ya des potes chez sfr
bah je sais pas peut-être maxime je
passe il s'entend bien avec maxime je
pense qu'il s'entend bien on a laissé
faire tourner avec les noirs alors
qu'ils étaient gagnants n'ont donc fait
ce qu'il veut il n'ya pas y'a aucune n'y
a aucune règle aucune loi qui l'y oblige
la rétro est finie gagné par cryptage
devant kostas mitroglou et bananes
vertes
ouais on voit que je dois non les
joueurs qui jouaient la prochaine s'ils
apprécient parce que parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de supporters parce qu'on
s'amuse parce que on se marre on se
marre sur les chat avec est belle on est
toujours en train de troller hier je
suis encore aller trop le truc
officielle donc c'était sympa on est
toujours en train de s'amuser avec cette
prod sheth ligue ont fait les cons on
n'est pas forcément là pour la gagne et
on est là pour pour faire les cons et
quelque part je vais vous dire c'est
même mieux je dirais que firoud déjà
pour nous c'est même mieux qu'il ait
refusé de jouer parce que moi on a notre
petit truc entre potes entre macha on se
prend vraiment pas la tête on se prend
pas au sérieux alors évidemment avec
fear où déjà on aurait été favori de la
compétition mais
voilà c'est on garde notre esprit de
vouloir troller de vouloir rigoler de
voir s'amuser bas qui m'a écrit tout à
l'heure il m'a dit qu'il voulait lâcher
qui voulait lâcher une grob peut-être
prochain match fou que ce match là il a
fait il a lâché donc voilà enfin joueurs
c'est bon esprit on rigole si on perd on
s'en fiche si on gagne on est content on
est là pour passer un bon moment pour
vous faire passer un bon moment aussi
que pour pour tous ceux qui nous suivent
et voilà c'est ça c'est ça l'esprit de
notre équipe donc c'est ça qu'on aime et
c'est comme ça que c'est le plus cool
comme le dit gaétan exactement si baky
baqi al cheikh al-cheikh la boutique de
ba qui dort au final c'est ça qui est
cool et c'est pour ça qu'on est
peut-être même mieux tu vois de rester
avec cet esprit là et d'avoir que des
gens dans le délire quoi
comme ça on est à fond dans le délire on
a en font pour se marrer et puis et puis
si ça sourit et qu'on gagne ça sourit on
gagne et puis si ça gagne pas ça gagne
pas si fait une grande mardi
ouais non mais bon voilà donc jean
roulland moment
j'étais exposé sur le ciel j'ai pas tout
compris eux qui se dit sur le truc
officiel en gros je dis que la
conviction était trop facile pour notre
équipe nos divisions étaient trop
faciles pour votre équipe ce que notre
équipe était trop forte et à qui on
voulait pas recruter d'étrangers pour
une équipe que foule français et qu'on
aurait espéré dans la ligue avec les
américains qui ont les plus gros budget
parce qu'on aurait une une compétition à
notre hauteur endroit en gros c'était ça
en gros j'ai trois comme ça en gros
c'était je dise à un peu comme ça mais
c'est en mode en mode semi troll quoi en
mode web c'est trop facile quoi
jaillissait 2 j'en arrivais à d'autres
partis qu'on suit vraiment arrive juste
à la fin
mais n'a pas fait de fan club pour pour
remplacer on devrait peut-être le faire
pourquoi on l'a pas fait parce que parce
qu'on s'est dit qu'il n'y avait pas
besoin et déjà beaucoup de clubs
beaucoup trop de clubs et voilà et non
laurent à papa pas refusé de jouer
j'aurai pas proposé j'ai proposé à jules
mais j'ai pas proposé à laurent jusqu'à
l'essai de pajr avec nous pour des
raisons qui lui sont propres et du coup
on avait on a une belle équipe comme ça
on a une belle équipe comme ça après
c'est vrai que jules il aurait mérité
d'être titulaire à paris sur la chaîne
je tape la honte ça me déprime non ça va
on est tous là pour s'amuser
donc ouais non on est une équipe on est
une équipe sympa tosh oui équipe c'est
un patch sur ce les gars je vous dis bah
demain du coup pour le stream je pense
qu'on va faire des parties pédagogique
compte les 1600 on verra et puis surtout
bon après on verra on verra ce qu'on
fait si on sa mission sur un peu de tft
si on fait un peu de bleach est pas on
verra
aussi que l'équipe n'avait pas été jugée
et les villes et à élaborer les vies les
villas pas compris il s'est dit il
centre au dessus n'écoutons pas à demain
du coup les gars j'arrête le strict on a
tout dit ciao ciao